Still with me? So here's my rules on trading somebody that has moved beyond the product stage and entered the photo of the old stage.
How do we know that? Well, we can test for it, but how would you know that not coming to me? So here, how would you know that?
That is the biggest way that you would know that you're at an auto of the old stage.
Well, let me save that question for just a second, because as I explain this, I'll answer that.
So this is my rule. If a person is auto-embeiled, they are stuck in either reverse and there's TH1 and TH2 side.
They are stuck in either a TH1 dominance or a TH2 dominance.
A person that has a very aggressive disease that is very debilitating and it's causing a lot of neurological issues.
And it's progressing fairly rapidly. Pretty good thing is that I tell doctors, pretty good thing to guess is their TH1 dominance.
Now it's really important to know that because it guides your treatment. If a person has cancer and this has taken 20 years to finally surface where they have a diagnosis, that like really acute is slowly debilitating and could kill them, but it's slower.
Pretty good chance they are TH2 dominance. I don't know if I can write in this book, but I think all cancer patients are TH2 dominance, but that's not it.
So there's a difference. You've got to treat these people differently.
Number two, what are or what is the primary antigen? And you know if you've got any study at home work online disease, there's about 100 different colon infections that go along with line.
So you've got to know what we're dealing with as the antigen. Remember the definition of antigen is that's the name that we give. Whatever pathogen that the immune system is turned out against.
So if I have a virus and it's a cold virus, a value immune system turned out against it, we call an immunology that cold virus in antigen.
So what is an antigen? What is the thing that the immune system has turned on against?
Okay? So this is a class on live, so we're assuming that we already try to know what the antigen is. It's live and it's colon infections, right?
But there's lots of people that come to us that you know they vet everywhere nobody can figure out is it's not live. They have an autoimmune disease and it's some sort of other pathogen that we have to figure out what it is.
But you do have to know what the antigen is that you're dealing with.
Number three, where is the concentration of the destruction? Remember if the immune system turns out against a virus, that's it by body, that virus can be concentrated over a period of time in certain areas.
Live disease, you read, maybe some people you know somebody who has live disease who has joint swelling and joint issues and arthritis and that's their primary concern but they don't have any neurological issues.
And another person doesn't have any joint issues but they can't remember anything anymore, they have brain fog, they have balance issues, in fact there's cerebellum, they're temporal lobe, they're frontal lobe and they have all this inflammation in their brain.
And where is the primary area of destruction? So the primary destruction is going to tell us where the antigen is located and you've got to treat that differently.
Next, how are we going to get rid of the antigen? Well that's the question of the day, how are we going to get rid of live disease?
This gets back to the first piece, is the patient TH1 or TH2 dominant. If you've already moved to an autoimmune disorder and you are TH1 dominant, there are certain nutraceuticals, you don't want to mean what I say nutraceuticals, right?
There are certain things that you can take or foods that you can eat that are going to stimulate a TH1 response.
And there are certain supplements that you can take or foods that you can eat with that would stimulate a TH2 response.
Now it's very important to know if I have a TH1 dominant line disease, I don't want to take supplements that are going to stimulate my TH1 side because my TH1 side is already on a balance.
And what does my TH1 side primarily do? Kill. Kill sticks. So if I'm going to take vitamin C, vitamin C is a TH1 stimulator.
I am going to help my body kill itself.
So if I'm going to take anything that will stimulate a TH1 response, what I'm TH1 dominant, I'm going to be 80 the destruction of my bicellalt tissue.
Following? Pretty important. This is the question that we get on the phone.
I started this vitamin C protocol that I felt better for the first week and that it's just like I was straight down here, I felt horrible, I felt worse.
Pretty good chance since patients TH1 dominant. I started at a cat's claw and garlic and I thought it started feeling better right away but that I just absolutely crashed.
Pretty good chance since persons TH1 dominant. There are a list of TH1 stimulators in my bone. You can download it for free.
There's a list of TH2 stimulators in my bone. Most of the time you look at any multiple vitamin, it's going to have TH1 stimulators on it.
Anything that will stimulate the immune response, any supplement that's going to be a immune stimulator is a TH1 stimulator.
So a lot of patients, an autoimmune patient up here, what kind of autoimmune disease it is, that has TH1 dominant.
It can't be any of that stuff. Very important because you think that you're hurt seed and I want to go through this hurts because I just got to get through it.
I got to kill this thing and you just destroyed your body. Can't do that.
How are you to kill this thing? We'll talk about that. Most patients that come to me that have chronic lung, quote unquote, they already know they have it,
are TH1 dominant, autoimmune, or they would come to me. They're already doing super bubbles with their chiropractor or naturopath or whatever. They're doing some information and they're doing pretty good. They don't need meat.
And how are we going to address the rest of the body? That's very important, too.
Because let's say if a person has all these neurological symptoms, they have inflammation in the brain because of the pathogen, let's say it's Lyme disease,
and they have this autoimmune TH1 response. Every time their immune system fires, that's the irony of the thing.
It's actually what I feel better is when my immune system is completely fatigue. And when I feel worse, it's what my immune system is.
Don't get it. It's going to go out there and kill that little bugger. That's what I feel worse. Because when it's killed it is not that little bugger.
It's killing my nerves. So you still have to doctor. You're going to look at how is the liver detox pathways, how is the kidneys functioning, how are we going to peel the blood brain barrier, how are we going to peel the liver?
You know the leak you got issue, how are we going to get the inflammation out of the brain, how are we going to rebuild the pathways?
That the immune system is already destroyed in trying to kill the Lyme pathogens. We got to rebuild the neurons.
I just want stuff to do on my patient.